I quit my job again. Hey, what's new?
Hey y'all
So it's been a while since I joined this vlog camera on because my battery died and I realized that I left my battery charger
In Japan, so my parents shipped it to me and I finally got it and it's here. Um, I'm about to eat some lunch
and then hopefully
Do some things in the afternoon
We'll see
I
Should tell you what, I'm eating for lunch. So oh hi caught you hey
Here's my neighbor's dog that we're watching for the day. Hi here
So I just made some
Ginger, uh dong which is just chicken broth Otzi you like a Japanese soup broth and then ginger and green
Onions and then this over here is leftover nikujaga
which is
Meat and potatoes basically, except there's only meat and carrots left. That's just leftovers
very tasty
Hey Wow
Oh, that's not you can't like that
Okay, all right we're back from the optometrist
Well, I did get worse. What are you doing Cole? What are you doing?
You trying to snuggle Oh cutie ha ha ha
um, see ya my eyes did get worse and
That's to be expected because it always gets worse a little bit over
Over the years and my doctor just said it's just because I spend so much time on the computer
So using computer glasses is something she definitely recommends. I'm gonna do that
So yeah, you all might be wondering why that footage was there from a week and a half ago
I quit my job again. Hey, what's new?
So I didn't really say this at all on purpose where I was working
But I was working at Netflix
So first time I've ever worked at a faing company and I was there for a year and two months ish
And it was great. I really enjoyed my time there. I had an awesome team an amazing manager
but I left and
the reason being because
I needed some time. I needed to take a break I think
I feel like I've just been kind of go go go for the last two issues
actually more than that three and a half years and I know that doesn't seem very long but also tech moves very fast and
I wanted some time in space to figure out where I wanted to take my career next
Because in a lot of ways, I feel like I've reached a check point in my career as an iOS engineer and Netflix
They don't they rarely promote people into management positions. And also I was doing iOS development and I
realized a little bit that
not everybody needs a app and I
Definitely like kind of burrowed myself into a niche in terms of software development
Which I did on purpose and I'm glad that I did
But where I wanted to go next was a complete blank in my mind not to mention just like I wanted
Also some time to figure out like hey if I wasn't gonna do software development
Or if I had the time and space to figure out what I wanted to do
What would it be as always? I've been doing a lot of introspection about like what do I want in life?
And where do I want to go for the first time?
I was kind of like, you know, I don't know I think my career
Thus far has been what I imagined to be from college and it's what I was working towards this whole time
but I'm realizing there's like a lot of a lot more other things that I want in life and
things that like my current job couldn't give me so
Yeah, I mean those things being things like being able to work more flexibly
Hours wise location wise being able to work on different kinds of projects building on
Certain skills that I wanted all the while. I wasn't feeling super fulfilled at my job at Netflix
And so in contrast like I was feeling very fulfilled in doing YouTube work. So it was just kind of this like
Just not working out
It's the the saying it chief kind of think and so I left
And I know that I'm in an incredibly fortunate position to be able to do so
and so I did I took advantage of that position and I did and
What I'm up to now is honestly
I've been fun employee for about a week and a half now and I'm cut I'm just using this time to heal
As I mentioned him I get ready for 2020 with a new video
I'm gonna experiencing lots of anxiety over the last three months and I think that this is a really good
Opportunity for me to keep regaining that balance and figure out what is the lifestyle that I want
And really think about where I want to go next. This doesn't necessarily mean that I'm like a full-time youtuber per se
I think I will keep making videos
but I just don't know whether this is what I want to do the whole time and if so like
How do I want to do it? So yeah, I'm kind of just keeping my options open being open-minded
Maybe I'll do YouTube. Maybe I'll do something completely different. Maybe I'll start contracting freelancing. Maybe I'll just get another iOS job
Who knows it's the first time that I feel like I can really make this decision for me without any of the other
that I need to worry about
So I'm gonna do that. I'm 27. This is a right time for a quarter life crisis
So, that's me now. So yeah, I've kind of just been filling my time the last like week and a half with chores and
hanging out with friends and
relaxing and eating good food and just
Chilling out honestly, which has been so good from my body
It's been very very good. So that's
The scoop on why I left and where I even was. It was really great
I really liked working at Netflix and I'm so glad to have had the opportunity to
Do that and work with the amazing people that I did
It just it just didn't work out like it was kind of like a breakup. It just wasn't working out and
That's ultimately my decision and I'll take responsibility for it
But I did grow a lot as a person and I'll take those lessons with me and I feel nothing but gratitude
Towards all of that
for the last year and a half so
All good things onward and upwards. You know, I I think
I'm hungry now and I kind of want to eat something cuz it's new. So let's let's make lunch
Okay, let's let's move on from this
Heavy topic and eat something. Yeah, let's do that. Okay
So I kind of want to film my vlogs in both Japanese and English
so when I speak Japanese will be subtitles below but